Jérôme Ouédraogo est membre de la compagnie
Palingwendé, avec laquelle il répète
avant une représentation.
Hé, Mabou !
Pourquoi leur quartier là-haut est toujours
calme comme ça ?
– Mais je ne sais pas hein ? – Hmm. Bon,
allons. – Mabou ! Moi je vais sonner.
Oh vas-y ! Vas-y ! Vas-y ! Gling-gling !
– Bonjour, Tonton ! – Bonjour fiston !
Richou. Willy n'a pas votre teint d'antan.
Aujourd'hui c'est jeudi et c'est jeudi et
après il a fait le coq et moi je pouvais pas
voir dans un foyer aussi hein. Ouais ouais,
il avait pas le temps. Mais attendez moi
j'arrive pas moi. Quoi? Oui oui oui.
Non mais c'est quoi ça ?
Ouais, tu veux bien ? Oh, tu vois ce que tu as
fait à mes amis ?
Oh ! Oh !
Rentre ! Rentre !
Oh ! C'est pas bien là-dedans!
Ahhhhhhh Oh !
– Mabou ! – Oui. – Euh, les enfants sales là,
Ce sont vos enfants ? – Je te permets pas
de dire que mes enfants sont des enfants sales
– Madame qu'on vient de salir.
Mais heu mesdames, attachez moi d'abord, je
vais m'énerver. Ouais, mais pas moi !
Oh mais non mais oui ! Oui ! Oui !
Bien souvent, les spectacles de marionnettes
sont donnés à l'occasion de fêtes,
anniversaires ou encore pour des arbres
de Noël du mois de décembre. Si on peut
considérer que les enfants y trouvent
leur compte, force est de constater que
le contexte ne répond pas au minimum
d'exigences qui permettraient aux artistes
de s'exprimer pleinement.
Bonjour Tonton, Bonjour, Fiston. On vient
prendre des nouvelles de notre ami, Joyeux
– Le joli lapin, il vous voit tout le temps !
– Mais Tonton, c'est jeudi.
C'est jeudi et après ? Foutez-moi le camp !
Les règles économiques, cette terrible
obligation de vivre ou plutôt de survivre,
font que les marionnettistes acceptent
souvent de faire un peu n'importe quoi
pour un cachet souvent dérisoire.